how's it going bros my name is Pippa I'm
here where and it's Valentine's Day
tomorrow or today
I don't know so what better way to spend
your Valentine than to play some games
with your partner no I'm just kidding
okay so even if you're alone on
Valentine's we got you covered
so legend of the brofist got a
Valentine's Day update so even if you're
a sad loser who has no one in your life
you can play this game and you'll still
be a sad loose I'm kidding don't worry
ah we love you know we don't okay so
here's the new level love is in the air
we're standing out while playing tears
so we can dance if you want
let's not no we're not doing pigma so
the developers told me that this level
is insanely hard so there we go
this is gonna be awesome so we're on
their top of clouds and I'm jumping on
top of you hey what a great start
haha this is gonna be so easy
yeah hey hey what are you walking here
no oh I'm a laughs don't jump on me
my oh my oh my god this is gonna be some
ah girl you cray cray this is making me
so anxious oh god no oh yes oh I'm fine
okay wait yeah we were fine and that was
just warm up don't worry about it
alright so I'm gonna go I'll meet you
over here why yes I am
don't worry about it just jump I think I
know wait wait wait look I'm a genius
oh yeah girl save me oh alright come
down here are you okay there
no don't die don't die don't die so if I
know this is just because microphones in
my way okay thank you you can't see this
Kushi you're short that's your own fault
yeah
I have no comment no uh-uh I can fly it
ha ha ha that's right okay no watch out
no I know everything okay see you later
my dear good see up your skirt right
soon okay
I like my nipples I always wanted my
nipples to be pixelated okay what are we
supposed to do I think down maybe not so
fast though maybe not just like yellow
down just like oh my god you're crazy
look at the rainbow so cute Oh God we
can do it no unicorn uh checkpoint good
oh yeah that's right hey what are you
walking here man how dare you have you
thought of a heart Hey
don't just go without me you're crazy
have you thought about how hearts kind
of look like butts what'd ya think about
him
okay we're supposed to go down here
awesome
boom that's it that's how it's done duck
mode you know those kind of movements
doesn't mean anything if you're bad yeah
oh wait for me oh my god yes yeah good
job girl I love house I see you look
like mmm I think oh yeah look at this
yeah
oh there this go Matt yeah go again my
dear yeah gum if you yeah
not we we'd Wow okay you did it sorry
I'm so sorry
how about I'll just Hey oh damn it damn
it damn it Matt yeah Sam too messy
Sam MS no we always think we're gonna
die you can jump over here right
hey get wings loser man it looks so good
who wouldn't want to buy this game we
can see my nipples that's it that's a
big selling point I don't think we're
supposed to be here don't tell anyone
they really do because they're so tiny
they're really hard to find
don't you found it right away what are
you talking about okay well I felt it
yeah yeah we did it oh my god hey yeah
are we supposed to be up yeah every
suppose be I'll wait for you don't I
I got a only I won't lay like wait hey
dr. crab me run doctor [ __ ] ah you
crazy yeah oh oh
it scares me every time it's like having
a safety net but you don't know about it
okay and now we go together later girl
together slow-mo yeah okay alright it's
okay
we did it you go girl you go girl hey
hey yeah yeah
it through the dance jutsu dance and
that was the Valentine's Day free update
that was so bad I'm so sorry no you were
really good yes uh we hope you enjoyed
this free update check it out see if you
can beat our score post your scores at
hashtag love boots see what I did there
it's really fun check it out and that
it's free Sam
there you go thank you for watching this
has been a great episode I got it
no beer leave a like if you enjoyed
watching and we will see you in the next
one
ruff it's them breathless